rentrée scolaire mercredi proche rené
monory ministre de l'éducation invités
d'antenne 2010 n'est pas satisfait du
calendrier préparé par son prédécesseur
jean pierre chevènement il a bien
l'intention de modifier la rentrée se
fera plus tard une semaine plus tard que
cette année en septembre 87
et puis monsieur monory veut également
modifié le rythme des journées scolaires
mais l annonce par le ministre d'une
modification du statut des directeurs
d'école on veut renforcer l'autorité du
directeur provoque une très vive
contestation du syndicat national des
instituteurs commentaire estelle bout si
un directeur d'école c'est un
instituteur comme les autres qui par
ancienneté accède à ce poste
il est ainsi mieux payés que ses
collègues mais n'a aucun pouvoir
hiérarchique
il enseigne en partie le reste du temps
il le consacre à la gestion de son école
rené monory se propose de modifier leur
statut actuel en leur donnant une réelle
autorité les directeurs pourront
notamment noté les instituteurs de leur
établissement en donnant aussi une
formation spéciale aux instituteurs pour
accéder au poste de directeur ils seront
également soumis à l'obligation de
service public c'est à dire ouvrir leur
école pendant les grèves enfin le
ministre veut accroître leur pouvoir
pour en faire de véritables chefs
d'entreprises des interlocuteurs
privilégiés auprès des chefs de famille
si certains syndicats minoritaires se
félicite de ce projet le snu syndicat
majoritaire qui est hostile c'est ce qui
manque c'est un cadeau empoisonné
parce que si le ministre accorde
effectivement des améliorations
financières au directeur il leur fait
payer cher la facture
pourquoi il leur retire le droit de
grève il va les contraindre à suivre une
formation pendant leur temps de loisirs
et puis ce qui nous semble encore plus
grave c'est que monsieur monory casse la
profession de en donnant une autorité
aux directeurs d'école il sépare
radicalement les directeurs des adjoints
or dans nos écoles élémentaires et
maternelles règne l'heure actuelle une
harmonie qui est
absolument nécessaire pour le travail en
équipe comme nous le souhaitons legault